uh or i'm very happy to be here and
again thanks for the organizing and all
the volunteers that make this
a conference possible yeah so today i'm
going to talk about uplift modeling
which is yeah it's related to
causality and machine learning when i
was preparing this talk and i was
writing the abstract i thought about
going through a specific example let's
say showing some code
and let's say going to the concepts at
the same time but this turned out to be
very challenging especially because
going into the literature and trying to
understand this like in a very kind of
thorough way it took a lot of work so i
kind of split this in two so what i'm
going to do today is mostly focus on the
concepts
uh but i did wrote like a like a kind of
a blog post or like a notebook on which
you can actually reproduce everything
that's here so that you can still
do it yourself uh yeah but i think
understanding the concept is actually a
in my opinion a little bit much harder
than understanding the code for this
specific example
all right yeah so what's the motivation
of this talk so let us assume that you
were given 100 euros and you just need
to run a marketing campaign and you kind
of identify customers which might turn
or might leave your your your service
so one way of doing that is let us
assume you have a voucher and you're
going to send an email with that
incentive the easiest way of doing that
is just send all the users a
all of the treatment
and that would work fine and then how
you measure your campaign well you just
estimate the number of conversions that
you have maybe like basket size or
amount in euros and that you will be
your success metric
but actually this is a little bit tricky
because we have different type of users
so the users that you would like to
actually have or like
having this in this campaign would be
like the the red the green one which is
the preservables which are the uses
which we're thinking about leaving your
product but they came back because of
your voucher
uh there are two other
type of users which actually you're kind
of wasting your your money because on
the one hand side you have the lost
causes that no matter what you're saying
they will never come back
and also you have the sure thing that
maybe they were just having like
vacations or they were on pause and they
would have let's say come back to your
product
without needing the the the incentive
but there's a specific
case a set of uses which actually on
which this
particular campaign actually was hurtful
and these are the so-called no disturbs
so this one was someone who could also
be kind of imposed maybe in vacation but
you send that email and you just piss
them off
uh
sometimes i'm one of these users so
uh
so you think about okay let us use some
historical data and try to just uh train
machine learning algorithms to try to
detect like a let's say which ones they
they have the probability of being the
specific groups and they just crack this
business case but the main point is that
you you can not send and send an email
to a specific user to try to measure the
uplift you won't be able to observe the
data and that's one of the key problems
in this type of of setting is that you
don't have like a true label to compare
against so that makes things a little
bit tricky
so what we're going to talk what we're
going to talk about today is it's
precisely about techniques of how to
estimate this a cultural effects
and there's a nice paper which is the
one that i'm going to follow most for
this talk is a
which is cultural inference and
uplifting modeling a review of the
literature
and yeah what we want to do is to
estimate this incremental impact
and as we will see this has two
components on the one hand side we have
casual influence again because we don't
have a
true labels but on the other hand we are
actually in in some cases being able to
estimate these treatment effects using
historical data through machine learning
approaches
so let me kind of set up some notation
and i'm going to keep it this very light
but we still need to be very precise
about what we mean with the specific
variables so let's uh why soup i they
know the person the outcome of person i
when it received the incentive let's say
the email and that's important this
little one and why i not is when it
doesn't receive that
and what you would like to compute is
the difference between these two which
is the cultural effect but again you
cannot know that and that's some but
still it's worth let's say aiming on
what we want to
estimate uh moreover if you have a set
of covariate let's say you have
information about the users could be
the attribution channel like how they
got your platform maybe geolocation data
or some other attributes then you can
have that in a feature matrix like in
usual machine learning which we denote
that x i which are a set of covariates
and you will be interested in the
expectation of the difference between
these two outcomes a conditioning on the
covariates and that's what we're going
to call the conditioned average
treatment effect again
we cannot measure this so we need a way
of
kind of hacking this out
and there's a way of course but there
always come with an assumption which is
very important to understand
so besides this a kind of variables that
introduced before let us denote by wi
it's a binary variable like one or zero
just indicating whether the person
received the treatment or not let's say
the email
so in reality uh what you measure is y
observe which is kind of this
combination so if you replace w by one
you will get y one i and you replace it
by zero it's y a
i zero
a so this is just notation so we haven't
done anything yet and now here comes
kind of the most important thing of the
talk which is the assumption on which
everything will not communicate
afterwards holds true
if we assume
that the treatment assignment is
independent of these observations
conditional on the covariates that's big
if
then we can estimate this conditional
average treatment effect by computing
the difference between these two
expectation values so if you think the
expectation values actually are think
about historical data you are going to
take the outcome of the users which had
a treatment and subtract
the
values or like observations for which
you say which didn't have a treatment
so a
the tricky part about the unconfounded
assumption is that you need to make sure
that this
there's no kind of hidden variables
which can be explained in the assignment
and and this is particularly tricky
because there's sometimes
variables that you don't know that might
kind of leaking information or making
this assumption fail
so a typical example of doing this is an
a b test when you try to do a random
split but i recently read an article
about saying that even if we if it's
random you could still screw up this
this assumption so i'm going to
reference that to to the to the end of
the talk because they they show very
concrete examples
so if you think about the next task so
assuming that we have this this
condition then we have collected some
historical data let's say from an
experiment and we i'm going to show you
how to estimate these two things uh
using any type of machine learning
problem
but as in every
problem the tricky part is really the
data
so how would you collect the data and
how you you will actually make this a
useful in your in your specific case so
the first thing you know you need is
some training data and for that you'll
do kind of a typical a b test where you
split your customers in control uh and
treatment and then you send a emails1
and the others you don't do anything and
you collect the outcome again the
outcome y could be a binary variable
like conversion like the converter or
not or it could be a revenue or like
basket size let us assume for simplicity
that is going to be conversions
after you do that you can trend your
uplift model which i'm going to talk in
a bit and then for a future campaign you
of course you don't want to do the same
mistake of targeting the non-disturbed
users you are going to use the
prediction of this offline of a oblique
model to target specific uses which you
expect based on historical data and
look-alike features from your covariance
matrix i'm going to
react positively to your treatment
it is recommended also that in the
second step we you still do a train uh
like a control and treatment split so
that you keep enlarging your training
data right because you don't you still
want to let's say keep doing this as
campaigns go over
so yeah the data collection actually is
the tricky part because you need to
ensure that the hypothesis and the
unconfoundedness assumption actually
holds
so there are many ways of estimating
this this uplift uh today we're going to
focus on what is called method
algorithms and these are kind of
when i was reading about it like
intuitively made sense the others one
seems to be also very powerful and
sometimes overperforming these ones but
get a little bit tricky so as we're
going to talk about this in a kind of
introductory matter i'm going to stick
with the meta algorithms
and
meta just means that we're going to use
any kind of
like arbitrary models to estimate this
difference between these expected values
so i'm going to talk about three of
these meta learners
the first one is called the s learner
and what we do here is the following at
the training step we take we have all of
a design metrics which i denote by ax
and then i create a matrix on which i
add a column which is a treatment so it
could be one or zero and i have the
outcome which i collected from my a b
test and i can use any machine learning
algorithm to to learn that
i'm going to call that mu
and whenever you have new customers or
at prediction time what you do is you
take that trained model and then replace
the features for the new users and then
replace the column
of the treatment to one and then
subtract the same thing by restricting
it to to zero so this is really similar
to what we saw like from the expectation
value that i showed you a before
uh notice that at training time i do
need the labels but at prediction time
i don't so that's the whole point i
so there's another possibility and this
is what is called the two learner is
that instead of having one algorithm
that learns this you actually train
on the treatment and the control group
separately uh and i call this mu c and
mu t
and of course you don't
have the column w in this case so judges
and these two algorithms could be very
different one could be a linear
regression i know there could be a a
tree-based method
and what you do to to estimate the
uplift is just to take the difference
between these two so it's it's a
in in essence it's
it's very similar to the s learner when
i was looking to these
[Music]
formulas i couldn't stop wondering like
are we actually estimating uplift from
noise because at this stage it's a
little bit tricky to see if this
associated uplift is just
the true uplift or it could be just this
error which is just being let's say a
fed by by the model
so
there are other alternatives actually
there are many learners i'm gonna just
stick to these three ones which try to
account for that
a
so this is what is called the x learner
so the x learner is this in step one
that's the same thing as the q learner
which is just take your two a take a the
train the test sorry the control and the
treatment group and trained two
algorithms on on them separately
but at prediction time we
we do something a
different so we first we compute
something what is called the imputed
treatment effects
and these are the following so for the
treatment group i take all of the
outcomes of the treatment and this is
why this is the first column and then i
subtract the predictions
using the
model from the control group
using the treatment a covariate i do
this for the for the in the other way
around for the control
this is somehow to to mix the control
and the treatment groups
and these by itself are all kind of
hinting like they're separately
estimates of the uplift if you think
about it
so if you want if at prediction time the
final step is once you we have you've
defined these d variables which are
inputted a cursor treatment effects then
you have yet another set of algorithms
which is called tc and t tau which
actually learn this
and these are actually by themselves two
estimations of the uplift so
you could actually take one or the other
or take a combination and that's
actually the final step which is just
take a combination of these two
with a weighting function g
a how to select this function
i guess that comes a little bit with
with experience and there are some trick
tricks uh some of them one of them is
actually to use what is called the
propensity score
and this is just defined as the
probability of having a treatment giving
the effect so yeah
when i was reading this it was a very
confusing because uh the kind of trying
to explain this it like to myself took a
a while because the intuition between
this detilder is kind of there but the
question is like why is this actually
better than the t and the s learner so
what i'm going to do next is to give you
a very concrete example
which i found in in a paper explaining
the x learner where we can actually get
some intuition of the things that could
work and that could fail
so uh and yeah this a simulated example
actually is is such that the treatment
effect or like the uplift is actually
equal to one so it's a constant we know
the answer it's a simulation
so i have two groups i have the
treatment and the control
the treatment in this case are the blue
lines and the control are the uh
the red dots or x's and the x-axis is
the covariate so anything that could be
used in our model and the y-axis is the
outcome
so if you see now the fit you have the
blue line fitting the these
these these treatment points and this
kind of piecewise linear one
feeding the control group so this is
actually what you would do this is one
example of
fitting a machine learning model to on
the a
training on the
test
sorry on the control and the treatment
groups separately so this is what the
first step of the two learner
for the two learners what you would do
is actually take the difference between
these predictions and this is what you
see in the a solid
black line
so this is what you would get by taking
the the difference between these two
field lines
and of course it doesn't work just
because kind of
this this this area on which the the
treatment goes up is actually not
working properly and the thing is we're
just looking them separately
so uh the dotted one which we'll see in
a bit of how we got there is actually
the estimation of the x learner so of
course in this example the x learner is
going to work better but why does it
work better well actually it's because
exactly this impurity treatment effects
so a i might not have the time
to go through it but
you can actually
kind of verify that for example the the
imputed treatment effects
of of the treatment group is actually a
straight line or like the fit in this
case which is the tower algorithm
whereas for the other one for the
control
is a
this kind of valley fit and you can
check that
i don't want to do that because it's a
little bit cumbersome and maybe also in
in the sake of time also it's explained
in the blog post
uh
so in this case we noticed that the blue
line actually
is what we want
uh
and the
actually the red one is not working
properly so in this simulation example i
could just i pick one but in reality i
don't know
but again i talk about the propensity
score which is the probability of the
treatment given
the covariates
so in this case on which the classes are
very unbalanced the propensity score is
going to be close to zero
so it's going to be small
so it's actually going to wait in this a
kind of convex sum between these two
the blue line uh
much more than the red one and this is
actually very close to a constant one so
i really hope this example uh allows you
to to understand let's say that there's
some
a hidden intuition that it has to be
kind of
obtained by looking this into let's say
beyond the formulas and the
formalism so there are some
many python implementations so i i
collected a couple of them so we have
custom ml from uber echo ml from
microsoft and there's another one which
is called scikit uplift a
scikit uplift has a very nice kind of a
diagnostics model so check them and
check them out but they are in essence
very similar
because
they give you the freedom to choose any
algorithm and just to try to estimate
these effects by taking this difference
so this for example is how you would
feed a a one of these metal learners in
casual ml so for this specific case i'm
gonna use a a yeah this his gradient
boost classifier from sklearn and i can
just select the the t-learner to to just
use this one for both the treatment and
the on the control group and then i that
i input that in into the base t
classifier a and i just called fit and
predict and you can get the the
average treatment effect which is the
average of the whole population and also
you can have like the
conditional average treatment effect
which is at in user level and you can
actually access the models uh to do any
type of debugging or or or or yeah some
quality checks on the models themselves
so again the code is not that a hard
what is hard is really to understand
what's going behind the food
so now we know how to off to estimate
the uplift but the
the next natural question is how do we
know if the estimation is good or bad
so uh
when you go into the literature there
are all of these plots which kind of
resemble what is called the area of the
curve in machine learning and
i naively thought that it was going to
be something kind of straightforward to
just translate from one to another but
it turned out it's not that similar and
i took a while to understand how to
evaluate this method so actually for the
rest of the talk
i'm just going to focus on how to do
this a model evaluation
so on the uh
on this side on the left hand side you
see how you usually evaluate like a
classifier you have the false positive
rate and you have the true positive rate
and
imagine that your model is outputting
certain probabilities but you are
interested maybe in the predictions
themselves so in the tax zero one so you
can vary the threshold on which you
split these classes and then by
computing this kind of quantities you
get this blue curve
and then you have two important things
one is that if you train a dummy
classifier
you will just get this a straight line
and if a perfect model would just go
into the kind of corner uh of the graph
so that the ir under the curve for a
perfect model is always one so a nice
measure that people use is the area of
the curve but if you look what you do
for the uplift model
you see various things so it looks in
essence the same but on the one hand
side the perfect model looks very weird
and also the perfect model change with
with the data so if you change the
problem that's going to change so it's
not like in this case on which it's
always there
uh also notice that the axes are
different uh on the x axis i have the
number of target users under the y axis
is the number of instrumental outcome
kind of the uplift
so it's kind of
same in essence but it's actually very
different of how this is computed
so hopefully
by the end of this talk when you go to
these papers you can actually get a
better feeling on how these are computed
so again the problem is that we don't
have the true labels
so there's no way we can actually know
the truth but we can still
do some work around or some kind of
sanity check so one thing that they do
or that is the the authors or in the
literature suggest is to a compute the
uplift by percentile and what does it
mean
it means that i take my model and i take
a i have all the uplift predictions for
all the users and i can do is i can run
the uplift predictions in decreasing
order so the highest one are at the very
beginning and the lowest one at the end
and this is just a vector
a of numbers and then i can group them
in percentile let's say from 0 to 10
from 20 from 10 to 20 and so on
and for these
kind of buckets i can estimate which
were
the number of users in the treatment
group where where the number of users in
the control group what was the response
rate in the treatment responded in the
control and i can estimate the offline
by taking the difference between these
two so i will kind of obtain a uplift
curve per percentile a
after i fit my
model this is how that looks like the
the red curve
it's the final difference and the yellow
and the green one are actually the
absolute so to say so if you take the
difference you will get
the red one and a nice model
it will have like a decreasing curve
right because we you have sorted your
uplift uh so you are expecting that you
when you take this difference uh
actually this still kind of conserves
the trend because you organize your your
uplift predictions in a decreasing way
and but that doesn't give you any number
it's kind of it's plot but you can it's
very hard to to compare plots if you
have different models we would like to
have a measure
but let's we're going into that
direction so using the same principle we
can actually uh
use something that is the cumulative
gain chart and i'm and in essence this
first part
this this factor y t over
y over n are essentially this difference
that i computed here
so there's nothing new
and i just need to scale by the number
of users
and
i can plot that
but again
going to the details is a little bit
tricky because it's it's a cumulative
sum
so it's not to take the cumulative sum
of the uplift but you first need to go
into the cumulative sum of the of the
of the absolute values and then do the
computations and this is something that
is hidden in the literature and just by
looking into the the concrete numbers
this is something that you realize so
yeah just be a little bit careful i of
course don't want to go into the details
it's not hard
but yeah sometimes i i found it hard to
really understand
the concept just from the from the
formulas
but if you do it
in kind of the expected way you get
something of this sort so you have the
percentiles again we're working with
these groups
and for each of these percentiles or
buckets you are actually computing this
a cumulative gain so you can actually
write it in python that's not very hard
a and then you just plot it so that this
chart is actually giving you a lot of
information so the last point of the
plot would be okay i've the percentile
is kind of 100 so i target all of the
users
and if this is above zero so to say this
is your cumulative gain so even if you
send the emails to everyone you still
saw positive uplift which is fine and
this is something that you at least
would expect
but notice that
there's a maximum and around 60 and 70
percent
and this is telling you if you haven't
said you wouldn't have sent the email to
everyone but maybe just of course this
is after feeding the model but to the 70
or 60 percent you have gotten much more
uh
uplift so the rest is just you're
wasting your your uh your your resources
right because you're targeting these
ones which are not going to uh
uh react positively to the
um to the treatment so even at this
stage actually people recommend that
this is very useful useful for marketing
managers because for the next time they
wrote the campaign they would have the
uplift list
and they would say okay let us make a
cut at i don't know six sixty seventy
percent and let's let's go through that
if we assume that the kind of samples
between the the split are are similar
and again this is why the data
collection is super super important so
uh if you're a marketing manager i think
this plot should make you very very
excited because if you think about this
it's not just about
a
kind of effects but in general but also
money because sending an email costs
money and also losing customers
just because they were not deserved it's
actually quite painful
so this we did for a percentile level
and there's nothing that prohibit us to
do this at user level right so instead
of having 10 buckets let's do 20 or 50
or actually take all of these users
uh
and and this is the generalization to
towards what is called the uplift curve
so you can just do the split as granular
as as as we can
and this is precisely the uplift curve
which is the blue line so this is
already zoomed in a bit but this should
be kind of the smooth version of this
one
so that's why let's say you see that if
there's like if if this curve is high
then you this is going to be a good one
just because we're expecting there's
going to be a kind of high leaf with
respect to
the
point which have given emails to to all
of the users but then there are two
lines of reference which are the purple
one
and
the red one
which are
the
a perfect model so to say
and the random one so let's try to
understand uh how does this work
so
i spent a ridiculous amount of time
trying to understand this plot because a
it has to do like how do they come up
with the perfect model if there's no
perfect
like there are no labels
so the way i did this was to go into the
source code of the scikit uplift package
and try to see how they were computing
this and and the idea is actually
a
quite simple but quite nice so here's
the the key point a perfect model
assigns higher scores to all treated
individuals with positive outcomes than
any individuals with negative outcomes
so that seems trivial but we we can
actually
call this in a kind of
deterministic way
so what we need to do is to make sure
that
when we do the errors is as kind of
small as possible and that's the whole
point of the computation
so
what are the errors where the errors are
the control users which had a positive
response
and they treat when they treat ones
which didn't so these were kind of the
bad cases so to say
so this is going to be a correction term
so what they do is to
take
let's say this is already when you're
evaluating your model you have some true
labels like they convert or not and you
have the treatment
uh
so
the the model is working like the
oblique model is working good uh
when these two are the same
meaning that you predict an up there's a
treatment there was a positive in a
outcome or there was no treatment there
was no positive outcome and then you
need to correct that by just taking
the arrows which are let's say
the biggest one so to say
uh and if you and and it's quite clever
because if you you add these two
then
think about it and the statement
actually
holds true
so if you plot this and again what you
need to do to compare all of these plots
is to take
the outcome of this a predicted perfect
uplift vector
the sort them in decreasing way and plot
that you will see this step a function
which if you think about it like take
your time afterwards please uh
it makes a lot of sense
this is an example of the models that i
use with real data so they capture in
essence something but of course the
models are not as good as the perfect
one and this is one of the things that
i'll comment later that actually getting
to the perfect of this curve is very
very hard
but now if we plot this step curve on
top of the uplift course that is output
from the diagnostics we see that exactly
uh
this is this has if
this coincides with the points on which
there's a jump in the perfect uplift so
in this plot that i show you here this
is kind of hidden
but if you uh go and mark the points
which are not interpolation but real
points this is actually the case so to
go to the from the
a green one which is a perfect uplift
curve to the purple one in the uplift
curve space so to say you just need to
apply this formula and this is something
that you can do er
relatively easily
all right
so this solves part a of the mystery the
the other part would be
how to to to evaluate the random model
so i mean one way of looking into it is
like okay it should start at the same
point and at the same point because i'm
targeting the the all of the users
but i like simulations
instead of sometimes thinking too much
about the math so what i did i actually
run a lot of dummy models which would do
very like random uplift and you see in
this plot in the in the in this upper
one
uh that it does fluctuate
but in the limit let's say or when you
zoom out uh at the scale of the perfect
model it's essentially a straight line
so
i also recommend a that when going into
this type of literature
to to work some simulations yourself
because it makes all of these
computations much more transparent and i
have i have a background in mathematics
but i
often get lost in this formalism
especially because of how they presented
in the in the literature
all right so in practice if you're doing
this in in real life what you could do
for example is take various learners
like the s the t and the x learner and
you can do uh
a in sample and out of sample prediction
you can still take your data from the
from the a b test and split that uh
in such a way that the right hand side
is an out of sample prediction so notice
for example that in this specific case
uh
the q learner was best on the training
set
uh but actually the x learning was a
little bit better on the test
and i think this has something to do
with the fact that the two learner might
be capturing just a lot of noise when
this technique is too different whereas
the ex learners really try to combine
the treatment and the control groups uh
in a more um
kind of efficient way
in my experience on like a very short
experience like playing out around with
these models it's actually very hard to
get a good uplift just because again
it's these are kind of proxy metrics a
and in literature often says okay
actually you can plot this without
having the perfect model to have a
better visualization i just left it
there so usually comparing against the
the perfect model it's it's maybe unfair
but yeah it's worth comparing against
the random one
uh
all right the in the literature you
often see a also
another type of curve which is called
the kidney curve
and this looks
also quite strange
uh but the construction is exactly the
same but you just take it change your
target metric that you are going to
compare so you do
you don't take this cumulative gain but
you take this kind of a
change version which is actually not the
difference
to compute this curve so why would you
like to do something like this well some
authors suggest that a
even though the uplift curve can be more
intuitively let's say easy to understand
this one actually depends on the
quotient between these two like the
number of control and treatment so it's
not going to be that biased against if
there's like a very unbalanced class
but the kind of the uh you can still run
the same type of analysis on which you
have the green curve which is the
perfect model pass it through this a
kidney curve and you get those plots and
then the best model or like a good
indication of a model would be the one
which has a better genie curve in maybe
the out of sample set
all right so uh you can still
go into the notebook
which i would can maybe probably do
to guide you uh
through through this
so you can find the presentation there
uh this is also linked to the github
repo
and then i took
a
i took one of the tutorials from the sk
uplift
a
kind of a tutorial set but i use
cultural ml
for it so hopefully this can give some
kind of different flavor on the results
the blog post is a little bit long just
because as every this is real data so i
do exploratory data analysis and that
takes most of the of the part
but at the very end you can
see
all of the simulations uh all of the
plots that i presented today and
specifically
how to compute this from scratch
so this is taking a lot of code from sk
uplift and try to a
extract the essence
so you can of course use the package
themselves you don't need to reinvent
the wheel but
if you really want to have like a
a complete understanding of this
i will still recommend to do this in
your free time so to say
so yeah here you have all of the code to
generate the specific plots that i show
here
so
uh yeah that's about the notebook i
strongly recommend if you're interested
in this topic to go and check it out and
also i'll be around in the conference if
you want to just
talk about this and or discuss about any
other topics in marketing which is where
i'm
working mostly right now yeah here are
the references
i collected just the ones which were
very useful for me that doesn't mean
it's exhaustive i would still like to
recommend the one by gutierrez gerardi
which is about this kind of review uh
there's some specific about the metal
learners but this one
randomization does not imply
confoundness is something that i found
last week
and i think it's a very interesting
paper
so people that are running a b test or
plan to run a b test
please check it out because there are
some hidden kind of challenges in the
data collections when doing this model
and that's it thank you very much
[Applause]
so thank you ron
so i have a couple of questions here so
yeah so there's a first um
first question on about uh so you play
with statistics and you need to have
statistical powers so actually what is
the order of
like what is the minimum
amount of sample that you need to to
start to play basically like uh
um
i don't have that on top of my mind
okay i think the
because it's not really because in an ab
test you want to compute like the change
in a specific metric
uh like conversion rate but this is
something that you want to estimate
at user level right and you just have
one observation pair per user so you say
in the training set so but i don't have
any kind of
threshold on what's the minimum sample
size you need to do this uh to make this
like reliable again we still don't know
the the target
itself
but i think that's a that's an
interesting question i assume it's maybe
like machine learning you shouldn't
start before like a thousand points
because otherwise you don't know what
but uh if you have good covariance and
usually in marketing you have you might
not have a lot of quality data so if you
have good covariates a and domain
knowledge
linear regression is not something that
can be discarded from the start
yeah simple model
so
second question here is
could you
[Music]
like compare this with what you have in
reinforcement learning basically i mean
could you like
i haven't worked with reinforcement
learning i'm more like of a clash is
classical machine learning patient
experience
but it would if you know just reach me
or write me i would be very interested
in knowing more about that
my impression is that it requires a
little bit more machinery and maybe data
but i could be mistaken
okay so next question
we estimated the uplift how would we
estimate if
it was statistics i mean if it is
statistically
statistically significant or not
basically again if you have a control
think about
i think this is a tricky question but as
far as for now which is the reason i'm
trying to
learn this is
there's still an opportunity just
thinking about
optimizing this without going kind of
very deep
so if you have this type of plot from an
experiment
it's already hinting you that
it like sending the treatments to
everyone could be just not the best
solution so sometimes you just need to
optimize on the fly
and that's one of the reasons on which
for example marketing managers would be
keen to understand this even if they
don't kind of reach a p-value level so
to say but definitely this is something
that if i find out i will write in the
in the documentation
i didn't see that in the literature also
i never saw this type of discussions
which made me wonder
so
another one is about
repeated tests so
uh
if you want like to repeat your
experiment or to like to repeat the test
uh and that you have already like your
data how do you i mean is it possible to
unlock that like do you repeat the
experiment by mixing people or like
changing the groups or yeah i think this
this is actually very tricky and in
practice i have it here this is from the
sk uplift part i think what
like for example if in your data
collection
part or a step you send a treatment
which is very different from the one
that you are going to
send in the second one then this
probably is not going to work so you
need certain type of consistency right
and also let's say collecting the data
in one country and applying this to
another actually
we probably violate the unconfounded
assumption so it could be that you need
to make sure that what you did in the
experiment for the data collection is
actually very representative with
respect to what you are going to do in
the second iteration which you still
want to collect data that's what they
suggest so that you keep learning this
because of course there's kind of a time
component there that you want to maybe
capture through just enlarging the the
the
the the training set for your for your
uplift model
okay so
one last one here
um
yeah so apparently you mentioned at some
point that you could like
filter some of the data
i don't you don't recall but apparently
uh
so the question is if you do that are
you going to create like a kind of the
co-founders and then like break your
things because actually maybe if there's
a selection of
it could be a latin variable let's say
to your finger and then like yeah i
think that's that's quite interesting
but also called into the application so
let's i i have certain type of
strategies for different type of of
users so
if i have uses which
are the ones which i'm gonna apply the
the the certain campaign maybe there's
an incentive of doing that and this may
be because i know there's uh
there's a potential of churn actually
there's a nice a
and this goes into this direction a
youtube video from pi data on which they
kind of see this holistically so
many companies or many use cases they
predict churn right maybe your company
has a subscription-based model and you
predict churn
that's not very useful by itself because
okay you predict that so so what right
so this is something that you could
potentially put on top of that because
if your churn model outputs certain
probability scores then you
most likely will have a
campaigns to a re-engage those users
based on that right if someone is using
already your product a lot why would you
send a voucher right so this would go on
top of the
uh
of the churn prediction model so that
you actually want to prevent churn and
actually in this model that now that i
mentioned it they go a step further
later in the kind of funnel of the
project and they use
something around
reinforcements reinforcement learning so
maybe if the one interested can check
this out this
pi data talk which is very interesting
okay maybe there is a time for one last
question in the rooms okay first
uh when i talk
let's say uh i have 10 candidate emails
and i've tested them and i want to send
them out to customers given their
covariates does this generalize to such
a situation
where it's not not to send or not to
send but
how to engage with this customer
yeah i guess
in this case would be like if your
treatment variable has many kind of not
just one zero but many of them
i wonder we could view
thinking about the machine learning
problem of multi-class classification
you can do maybe once versus all and try
to do that so this is something that
might be interesting to see so you still
do that and then you have various uplift
for like say one versus all and try to
compute like uh the final one but i
don't know this is something that
i yeah actually the literature is not
that advanced in that case for these
specific introductory talks but i would
do it this way i would at least
that's what my intuition
suggests thank you
so thank you i think
so if you have other questions we have a
break now so you can go and see pray run
in during the lunch and ask him more
questions so thank you
and we can upload
thank you